[Music]  our show airs at 11 p.m eastern time  okay but a lot of our fans dvr the show  and they watch it on their own time  which is cool but i thought it'd be fun  to do some comedy that is geared  specifically for those people with dvrs  so ladies and gentlemen i don't think  anyone's done this before here's a  comedy bit that you can only see by  using the pause button  it's called comedy for dvrs  [Applause]  [Music]  all right tonight's installment is  rejected game of thrones characters  that's right enjoy  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  yeah  oh man i'm gonna get home and pause so  hard  two of the names in there are pretty  funny  enjoy finding them all right  [Laughter]  someone's gonna get really mad